el cirujano llevará a cabo una resección
del colon que es la extracción de parte
de su intestino grueso si tiene cáncer
colorrectal o muchas otras afecciones el
colon es un tubo muscular largo ubicado
al final del tracto intestinal
después de que el estómago y el
intestino delgado digieren los alimentos
el material restante pasa a través del
colon dónde se absorbe el agua y los
electrolitos
las heces residuales pasan a las últimas
6 pulgadas del colon lo que se conoce
como el recto donde se almacenan hasta
que se evacua la mayoría de las
afecciones que se tratan con recepción
del colon se dan en la capa de células
que cubren la superficie interna del
colon conocida como el revestimiento
mucosa
la recepción del colon normalmente se
realiza para tratar el cáncer
colorrectal uno de los tipos de cáncer
más comunes también se utiliza para
tratar otras afecciones como la
obstrucción intestinal
colitis ulcerativa y enfermedad de crohn
traumatismo en el intestino
pólipos de colon especialmente cuando
son muchos y grandes
complicaciones de diverticulitis
el intestino isquémico
antes de la cirugía se le aplicará
anestesia general para que duerma
durante toda la operación se insertará
un tubo respiratorio por la boca y en la
tráquea para ayudarlo a respirar
el cirujano comenzará haciendo una
incisión en su abdomen sobre la parte
del colon que debe extraerse
el cirujano sujetará su colon con pinzas
en dos lugares a cada lado de la sección
que se extraerá luego cortará el colon
donde se encuentra cada pinza y extraerá
la porción enferma del medio junto con
un martín de colon saludable y tejido
circundante
finalmente el cirujano coser a los
extremos sueltos del colon para unirlos
después de terminado el procedimiento el
cirujano insertará uno o dos drenajes
para eliminar el líquido que puede
acumularse alrededor del lugar de la
cirugía cerrará la herida con suturas o
grapas y la cubrirá con vendas después
de su procedimiento se le llevará al
área de recuperación para observarlo de
cerca y se le administrarán antibióticos
y medicamentos para aliviar el dolor
según sea necesario recibirá líquidos y
nutrientes mediante una vía intravenosa
luego pasará gradualmente de recibir una
dieta líquida a una sólida con el
transcurso de los días se le animará a
levantarse de la cama y moverse lo antes
posible